so I'm watching this new series Atlantis
on BBC America and it is ludicrous the
premise of modern-day dude named Jason
oh I see what you did there
gets transported to the fantastical
realm pre-emergent where he battles a
Minotaur pals around with the mythical
demigod Hercules and the non mythical
mathematician Pythagoras tell him about
non Euclidean geometry Jason is it
nonsense sure will I stop watching
absolutely not
Greek mythology is just inherently great
TV you got swords sorcery superhuman
feats of strength and agility giant
monsters power play is between deceitful
gods it's bulletproof material that even
a $75 per episode effects budget can't
ruin which makes me wonder
why is it so hard to get a serious based
on wonder woman off the ground she's
only the most famous female comic book
character ever and Amazonian warrior
princess from Greek mythology get what
I'm saying
she has magic bracelets that repel
bullets and a magical golden lariat of
truth let's just run this down TV
audiences love mythological heroes
TV audiences love kick-ass lady
protagonists TV audiences love comic
book characters given the right twist in
/ foot writers love that Wonder Woman
gets captured and tied up a lot so when
was the last live-action Wonder Woman on
the air sorry Lynda Carter but that show
was a cheesecake she's fast in 2011 a
Wonder Woman series on the CW didn't
make it past the pilot an NBC series in
2012 didn't even make it off the drawing
board oh and don't even get me started
on Joss Whedon's cancelled movie
adaptations have you read the script
online it's better than the Avengers
absolutely ridiculously now yes it's
true that Zack Snyder just cast Gale
gato is the Amazonian princess for a
supporting role in Superman vs Batman
what why not Gina Carano or Beyonce and
presumably Wonder Woman will be in the
Justice League movie but 1d could carry
a project on her own ah which I could
lasso all of those dunderheaded TV execs
with a golden lariat of truth and make
them tell me how they managed to fail
with K fail material maybe if I
sacrifice a few our oxen to Zeus
they'll send down some lightning bolts
to get the show out of turn
wrong lightning-bolt what superhero do
you like to dress up as let me know in
the comments who do you think could play
Wonder Woman in the upcoming TV series
that someone should be making let me
know in the comments and please
subscribe to the wire channel